foreign
[Music]
animals in case you didn't know either I
chew gum or I smoke
what are these children yours that's
mine from wives one and three there's
five bets from husband two Wilder is
ours we're each other's Force
[Music]
hope it lasts forever
[Music]
let's watch a sitcom or something
they're calling it The Airborne Toxic
Event they won't come this way will we
have to leave our home of course not how
do you know I just know okay what if
it's dangerous
we have a situation
all we have to do is stay out of the way
technically that's illegal
do sheep have lashes ask your father
we're going sideways dad do sheep have
lashes doesn't anyone want to pay
attention to what's actually happening
I wish there was something I could do I
wish I could out think the prop
there are two kinds of people in the
world
killers and tires
most of us are Dyers
[Music]
right now we're safe as long as the
children are here they need us for some
persistent sense of large-scale ruin
we keep inventing hope
I don't know